Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video all about
spider-man 3
bringing back jamie foxx's electro
character that's right
big time sinister 6 action so explain
what's going
on it's crazy that they're finally
canonizing some andrew garfield
amazing spider-man franchise to the mcu
but they did it with toby maguire
spider-man and j
jonah jameson if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we'll do a new amazon
giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the andrew garfield
spider-man movies
everyone queue up the clip of andrew
garfield just waiting in the wings to
get that phone call to come back himself
so just starting with the big stuff
first number five hollywood reporter
announced that marvel is bringing back
jamie foxx's electro from the amazing
spider-man 2 for spider-man 3.
the same way that they brought j-jones
jameson back from the toby maguire
spider-man movies
this obviously seems like more
live-action spider-man into the
spider-verse easter eggs as marvel
pushes deeper into multiverse
storytelling
originally the character was going to be
a member of the sinister 6 team that
they were creating in the amazing
spider-man 2.
at the time sony had plans for both
amazing spider-man 3 with andrew
garfield
and for a spin-off sinister 6 movie
franchise
drew goddard the person behind the
netflix daredevil series was going to do
the sinister six movie and even though
there weren't a lot of plot details for
that movie other than the roster that
they teased in the amazing spider-man 2
post credits scene
being green goblin putting the team
together made up of vulture doctor
octopus
rhino electro and craven the hunter what
ended up happening with that though is
that obviously we all know that they
decided to not do amazing spider-man 3
and recast
tom holland when they went to captain
america civil war so cut to a couple
years later tom holland shows up in
civil war and you have your brand new
spider-man franchise
however you felt about the amazing
spider-man films andrew garfield himself
actually says that he feels like he's
kind of heartbroken
with the way that they treated the
character it's actually pretty sad
listen to the clip of him talking about
it
that's something that happened with that
experience for me where it was
story and character were actually not
top of the
the priority list ultimately got it yeah
and maybe that's
i found that really really tricky i
signed up to serve the story and to
serve this
incredible character that i've been
dressing as since i was three yeah and
then
there's it gets compromised and and
it breaks breaks breaks my heart story
and character
not so important so it just sounds like
they're trying to freshen up a lot of
amazing spider-man elements inside the
mcu
give him a good polish and speaking of
mcu crossover thanks to the sony leak a
number of years ago
we actually found out that when amy
pascal was still head of the sony studio
she actually phoned him up and had him
read the amazing spider-man 2 script
look at some of the dailies and give
them advice on how to make the movie
better
i'll explain what he said because he
actually spoke a lot about jamie foxx's
electro character when he gave them
notes on amazing spider-man 2. so it is
kind of bringing things full circle that
kevin feige
sees electro come into the mcu
full-blown but number four just to
clarify the report is that they're
bringing jamie foxx
back as his version of electro they're
not going to do a rebooted version of
the character with a brand new origin
story
i know that when they brought j-jone to
jameson back in the spider-man far from
home post-credit scene
he looked different and they were going
for more of a vlogger thing by turning
the daily bugle from a
traditional newspaper into a video
podcast sort of website
but that wasn't meant to be a big
multiverse twist so it sounds like the
electro
inclusion won't be a big multiverse
twist
they'll find a way to incorporate his
pre-existing backstory that we got
during amazing spider-man
2 into the mcu and explain how he's
connected to the other mcu characters
the way that other sinister six
characters like mysterio were connected
to iron man during spider-man far from
home
like he used to work for stark tech got
a little bit crazy tony stark wound up
firing him and that's when he turned
into the villain that he is in the movie
and even though his backstory during the
amazing spider-man 2 was that he worked
for ozcorp
and obviously we want to get to oscorp
norman osborne green goblin in the mcu
eventually
in the original comics he actually
worked for stark industries so them
saying that he used to work for iron man
just like mysterio just in a different
department
wouldn't be too far off the way that jk
simmons explained his post-credit scene
though is that he's supposed to be the
same jay jonah jameson from the tobey
maguire spider-man movies just a little
bit older with
less hair and at some point in the last
15 years or so since the events of tobey
maguire spider-man 3 at least the time
period
the daily bugle just evolved into what
it is during the spider-man far from
home post-credits scene
but the way the mcu works is that tom
holland is the very first version of
spider-man
so even though he's coming from the toby
spider-man films it's just that time
period
so jamie foxx will be the same version
of electro but his backstory will be
sort of weaved in with mcu history so
that it all makes sense and it's all in
continuity
and explain the kevin feige connection
to elektra a little bit more
one of the biggest notes that he gave
them on the script for amazing
spider-man 3 and the dailies was that he
liked a lot of the stuff that they were
doing with jamie foxx's electro he liked
his performance
but he thought that they got a little
too crazy and a little too over the top
with him
at times like when he's going crazy in
his room here starting to go real nutty
this is one of the things that kevin
feige told them to get rid of obviously
you can see that that stayed in the
movie they didn't take a lot of his
notes so
now that kevin feige has control of
these characters and he's going to be
using the electro character he can
polish him up however he wants
the reason why amy pascal came to kevin
feige for help with amazing spider-man 2
when they were running into problems
with that movie
is because kevin feige was a producer on
the tobey maguire spider-man movies with
sony
before marvel studios became the big
studio that it is today
but number three obviously the next
question is because they've now
canonized elements of toby maguire
spider-man movies and andrew garfield's
amazing spider-man movies to the mcu
will they eventually bring back both
toby and andrew
in another new spider-man movie at some
point like live-action spider-man to the
spider-verse
amy pascal said that the studio had
discussed doing live-action spider-man
into the spider-verse before
but because the animated movie traded so
heavily on miles morales i had actually
assumed that
any live-action version of that movie
would include him and they haven't said
anything about introducing him in a
bigger way in the mcu yet
but here's the thing if you actually
listen to a lot of the behind the scenes
of the animated spider-man into the
spider-verse movie
the producers said that they tried to
bring back andrew garfield
toby maguire and tom holland's versions
of spider-man
to incorporate more live-action versions
of spider-man in the multiverse in a
bigger way
like there were a couple live-action
scenes that they incorporated into that
apparently they had much bigger plans
but at the time around 2016 or 2017 when
they were pitching that idea to sony
about bringing
all the spider-men back they said that
the sony executives
said that it was too soon to do a
crossover like that
right now though is just electro coming
back from the amazing spider-man movies
for what seems like more sinister six
setup they haven't said anything about
kraven yet in the movie other than
hinting that he might be one of the
villains
the news reports didn't say if electro
was supposed to be the main villain
but you don't bring someone back that
big for just a two second cameo
so it sounds like whatever he's doing
during the events of spider-man 3 it'll
be a bigger storyline than what jj
got in that post-credits scene screaming
about how terrible spider-man
is number two right now the sony people
have already said that they're setting
up an mcu sinister six team
but they're also using the morbius movie
in venom two the other venom spin-off
movies to do that as well
the current roster that they have right
now is the vulture
scorpion shocker and mysterio there are
a lot of hints that they gave us that
mysterio isn't actually dead at the end
of that movie or at least a version of
mysterio will come back at some point
because you have his henchman another
stark tech employee that stole
all of mysterio's files and mysterio is
kind of like a mask
that someone wears he isn't an actual
super villain it's all smoke and mirrors
so to speak
supposedly the reason why the vulture
shows up in the morbius movie after
showing up in the spider-man homecoming
post-credits scene in that same white
prison jumpsuit
is because at some point in the movie
morbius is supposed to be sent to the
prison where vulture is being held with
the scorpion
but even though they've said they're
doing sinister sick stuff in the mcu
they didn't say
when they're doing that like a lot of
people have wondered if spider-man 3
will be a sinister six movie or if
they'll just be setting up more sinister
six characters and they'll leave that
for spider-man 4.
so number one wtf obviously does that
mean that spider-man 4 will be the
full-blown spider-man vs the sinister
six movie
because it sounds like their spider-man
vs venom movie will be something
different but for those of you that
don't know about spider-man 4
a while ago when sony and marvel made
nice and they signed a new sharing deal
to share the spider-man character
the president of sony was asked about
doing future deals with marvel will you
continue
to share spider-man after the next
movies that you've signed for and he
said yes
so right now the contract for marvel
using spider-man with sony is that they
get him for spider-man 3
and another crossover movie in the mcu
that's kind of a mystery they haven't
said which movie he's going to show up in
but after the mystery crossover movie is
when sony and marvel would have to sign
another new sharing deal for tom hall
and spider-man spider-man 3 is supposed
to start filming later this year pretty
soon according
to tom holland so we'll get some more
news about that really soon doctor
strange 2
multiverse of madness will also start
filming very soon
big spider-man easter egg 2 sam raimi mr
spider-man himself from the toby era
will be directing doctor strange too
so there is a lot of spider-man related
stuff happening in the next couple of
years
so everyone let me know in the comments
what do you think about them bringing
electro
from amazing spider-man 2 and which
other characters do you want them to
canonize from the andrew garfield era
i know everyone's just going to say bring
andrew garfield back in some fashion
while you wait for everything click here
for that brand new avengers one division
trailer in easter eggs and click here
for that brand new mandalorian season 2
trailer in star wars easter eggs thank
you so much for watching
everyone stay safe this is the way!